we have from
thepostmillennial.com Joe Rogan
challenges I love this vaccine
enthusiasm Enthusiast Peter he loves
them to debate RFK Jr I just get this
idea
boost me now boost me now and give a
boost to debate RFK Jr on misinformation
now we all know the rules of the road I
don't want to get into any of the
specifics because Luke rudowski had
played some of the argument Ian you have
the story what happened to Luke when he
played just a clip of RFK from Joe Rogan
don't actually play the clippy no I
won't I don't even know I didn't see the
specific uh I don't even know if the
video is still up um but I just saw that
Luke tweeted it out that he reposted a
clip of RFK talking with Rogan I imagine
from that show or from the episode and
that YouTube is like your entire channel
is now demonetized yeah so not just that
video is the entire channel that is
really harsh that is really harsh and it
takes a lot for me to say that about
anything that happened to Luke that's
rough yeah yeah it's sad to sympathize
with Luke and I'm going to because I
stand up for all all Americans and All
Humans Free Speech must Prevail well
there are better reasons there are
better reasons to to you know clamp down
on Luke he's he's off of this I I don't
think what he did here is uh is right
here so we now see that we now see that
Joe Rogan uh he made the huge offer
that's got massive on Twitter uh Tim
Prime was offering money hundreds of
thousands of dollars I think it's up to
1.2 million the last time I checked of
money that would be donated to charity
by the way if Peter Hotes MD PhD were
willing to go on to Joe Rogan and debate
with him about uh with RFK about the
about vaccines about the use of vaccines
vaccine mandates mRNA vaccines all of
these different things because they've
both been on Joe Rogan and now this
isn't like he has to go on and win the
debate this is just if you will are
willing to do this all of this money
will be donated to the charity of your
choice
and then of course he's saying I won't
do this uh there have been arguments
he's calling it threatening he's calling
it harassment
hundreds of thousands of dollars
that's a threat oh my goodness and so
what I want to ask is is this what do we
think well should the debate happen and
and here's the question that I want to
put out because I stand for free speech
I think do we all agree on that yeah we
all agree well we all Americans we all
believe in debate here's my question
though
is a public debate the right way to do
medicine is this the right search for
truth is because that's of course that's
the response and so Devil's Advocate is
he saying well wait a minute that's not
how we do science uh you just were
talking about before about dialogue with
uh synthesis how can you have synthesis
if someone's just writing something's
wrong how do you respond yeah so what I
would say is that dialogue or
conversation with non-experts is not a
way to reach conclusion on or reach a
clear conclusion on any medical question
but that's not what's being discussed
here what what is being asked is whether
he can justify telling all of the
American people that they have to and in
many instances should be required to
either by law or mandate from their
employer to get this particular medical
treatment okay so there's a difference
there's a difference between saying the
medical process should be do determined
based on a single public conversation
between a doctor and somebody who isn't
a doctor and saying well if the medical
science is as clear as they're claiming
and all of our concerns about people who
were scientists and who were doctors
being pushed out of the establishment
and silenced for their views can be
nullified and aren't actual concerns
then should this man who advocates for
the use of this particular medical
treatment be able to explain to the
American people with an adversary in the
room that this treatment is worthwhile I
would argue yes and I would argue that
while not everyone is skilled at
debating and therefore not going to be
equally capable of promoting a message
even if it's truthful
if he's not talented in this area or
rhetorically gifted enough or quick
enough on his feet to engage in that
kind of a conversation what he should do
is find somebody who is capable of
defending the position and then that
person should go on Joe Rogan and make
RFK look like a fool and then have well
over a million dollars donated to a
charity of this man's choice and also
convince a large vaccine skeptical
segment of the population that they
should get the job that's what should
happen so you're arguing for a uh that
that Peter Peter Hotes can choose a
champion if I think it's a trial by
combat exactly no exactly if he's not
gifted enough to debate look that's
totally fair not everyone has to debate
not everyone's equally good at it it's a
different skill set at the same time if
someone offered me over a million
dollars to a charity of my choice to
have a conversation about something I'm
an expert on with someone who I claim is
a crackpot conspiracy theorist I cannot
imagine a rationalization for turning
that down I really can't and I'll say
this there are conversations that I
think are genuinely damaging so if
someone is promoting a new idea that the
culture is already completely against
and you could be giving legitimacy to
that idea by debating them so for
example if someone were saying that we
should have a public dialogue about the
acceptance of pedophilia I would be
unwilling to engage in that kind of
conversation because the public is
already against that and having a
conversation about it could give
legitimacy to that idea but this is
totally different but this is totally
different because the Public's against
it or did you just be against it well
because we're I think I also think we're
hitting moral Bedrock there where it's
just fundamentally obvious why this
thing is disgusting and you shouldn't
give voice to any opposition who would
say that something like that is morally
acceptable but this is different these
vaccines in this particular other kind
of vaccine is something that has been
pushed under the American people which
the American people have not
wholeheartedly accepted at this point so
the burden of proof is actually on the
person introducing the new idea to have
conversation about it and they've been
unwilling and one last thing I'll say
about this is
all of the arguments that are being made
about the concerns that the medical
establishment has about making
conspiracy theories seem legitimate by
having conversations and debates
defending their Viewpoint are arguments
that they would have made about
defending the wet Market hypothesis
three years ago and we know how that
turned out so these people don't have
the scientific or moral Authority that
they have claimed that they have this
isn't a situation where we should all
sit down and shut up because they've
been right about everything they've been
proven wrong and with a track record
like there it is completely and
abundantly reasonable for the American
people to ask for a little bit of
transparency and have one of these
people have a public conversation about
what they're promoting to the American
people with one adversary in the room to
be able to give them some pushback
that's what I think I was just thinking
about the companies that make vaccines
and other medicines and how when you're
a corporation you have a duty to your
your stockholders to make money so that
there's already a thing like don't make
us sell less because we'll lose money so
we have to and like why is there a
profit motive in the medical industry
that is incredibly wrong so you want
socialism I'm kidding I want healthy
people I want to talk about diet I want
to talk about what Rogan was talking to
Peter Hotes about when he had him on a
show in the beginning which is what do
you eat and Peter's like I eat junk food
and Joe's like are you kidding me
there's so much evidence that eating
healthy gives your body resilience
against covet as much as men as much as
other things that you can get and
vitamin D do you take supplements and
Peter's like I don't really take
supplements he's like this is crazy that
you're you're a doctor but you don't eat
healthy and you don't take supplements
so I want to hear that conversation I
think Peter's probably very nervous to
get humiliated in public about his diet
um and also I think he's he's on on his
own against RFK Jr and Joe because
they're both as far as I know I'm very
much like eat healthy that's the
beginning and so I think it would be
reasonable if Peter brought another
doctor in with him yes and there was a
four-person debate even if Joe wants to
be a moderator I think he's biased about
this for very evil whatever
um and I know that Peter loves Joe but a
guy went to Peter's house hotels and
like got his camera up and was like why
aren't you doing I need to watch the
video yet but that's where Peter's
saying he's being harassed
um don't go to his house don't go to
people's houses this started on Twitter
keep it on Twitter which people were
kind of writing off at first they're
like oh yeah this never happened because
he like took to the tweet and he's like
um oh by the way I was just harassed at
my house and I think like a couple
conservatives like hopped on like oh
yeah just like juicy smolier you know
like or does he smell like like he was
attacked and then there was like video
evidence that it actually did happen and
then what yeah even before we jump on
these stories guys wait wait before you
call somebody a faker like yeah yeah
exactly one thing I love about the right
is that the go the goal polls always
shift for us and by the way like I know
I'm kind of like crapping a lot on
conservice today just because uh you
know somebody said like oh that Hispanic
guy is probably a rhino which is
actually accurate I'm a republican in
film only because there is no political
movement right now that actually truly
represents and harnesses my outward
angward anger toward the government
um you know what I'm saying and so yeah
I am a republican name only but
Republicans get a lot wrong Michael
Knowles that at a conservative event he
said the Republican party is a party of
no Democrats present solutions they
might be they might be wrong they might
be uh stupid they might be outlandish
but at least they have Solutions and
Republicans are just a party of no you
know the Democrats are like oh we want
this health care and they're probably
like nope okay but what Solutions do you
have then and then the problem is that
there just really isn't a lot of those
Republican party but as far as the
debate goes
um I think it absolutely should happen
I'm kind of like with you you know even
what you were just arguing against I'm
actually for it like dude let these
people make you know uh uh an example of
themselves like there was like that Ted
Talk that we're talking about like it's
time to talk about Minor attractive
persons bro identify every single person
that attends that Ted Talk and look into
their into their computers you know what
I mean like to me it's like bro why why
censor any of this this is why you know
like I I love turning point and I love
other conservative right but it's like
we self-censor people that we consider
too radical you know and it's like I I
understand a lot of it has to do with
like donors and like Public Image and we
don't want to be associated with some
people but it's like dude if if you're
right then just go ahead and like make
the argument for it you know like again
and this is why it kind of like uh irks
me when it's like we claim to be like oh
we're all about free speech like well
what about this guy like a little move
like that's a little bit too much for us
like we can't talk about that because
you know censorship donors whatever it
is sponsors you know and to me it's like
dude just talk about it and just debate
it and like if the person is wrong then
the person is wrong right you know
I mean the thing's gonna reveal the
truth honestly is just putting it into
open discussion I I yeah I don't
entirely uh agree I think that showing
certain uh Lifestyles or bad behavior
can actually normalize it though I think
we're probably gonna have to agree to
disagree on that point if we're having a
broader conversation about whether this
debate should happen my main point here
is that even with the framework that you
can argue like an expert shouldn't be
having a conversation with a non-expert
about this or there are some ideas so
heinous that it would be wrong to
discuss them or debate them publicly
this certainly doesn't fall into that
category and I'll also add this we'll
just hold on um I will also say here
and that what is being what is being
posited here is a a non-medical expert
having a debate on a podcast with a
doctor now interestingly enough I
actually think that would debatably make
it more of a layup for the other side
right what they should be saying is it
wouldn't be right for me to debate a
non-medical expert therefore get me a
doctor get a doctor on your show who
disagrees with me so he and I can have
the conversation or get a panel of
doctors let me bring other doctors who
are specialists in the different field
uh that that are the different fields
that would contribute to this
conversation and then you get doctors uh
who are on the other side of the
question but it's not enough Dr Malone
maybe thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time